my libertarianism would be not deontic
libertarianism like you know there's a
philosophical libertarianism that you
know freedom comes first good right and
so much as I want errors to be
multiplied that's it
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Nasim Nicholas
Taleb Talib's latest book is
antifragility things that gain with
disorder which looks at how to create
institutions that can survive in the
face of chaos and adversity thanks for
joining us thank you thanks a lot let's
talk about antifragility what is
antifragility as you discuss it in the
book and you know why is it so important
okay first I need to present the tell
you what fragility is okay once you're
mad fragility is what does not like
volatility then then you can realize it
well that the opposite would be
something that likes volatility and
lights variation like Saturn more like
stress like stress up to a point and the
opposite would be robust robust is like
a rock doesn't care diamond is robust
perfectly robust what is anti fragile
gains from this order and effectively
may even need this order for fuel so
here you have three categories for
objects the fragile doesn't like
volatility the robust doesn't care the
resilient the adaptable really doesn't
improve from fresh and you talk about it
in terms of you know materials that
robust thing you mentioned a rock or a
diamond it's it's just there it doesn't
it doesn't gain but it can shatter from
being kind of up to a point you know
you're always robust or fragile as you
fight up to a point right and but then
for anti fragility and fragility applies
more to kind of systems or human living
organism exactly what what people fail
to understand and this is
we're libertarians tend to pick it up
rather quickly that even when you read
Adam Smith's you have this illusion that
the economy functions like a machine
it's not a like washing machine the
washing machine needs maintenance it's
more like a cat than a washing machine
so this human body needs some stressors
and everything organic and complex
communicates with the environment via
stressors so give a you know when you
say the economy is not like a washing
machine it's more like a cat I mean
that's basically it's it's an organic
whole or an organic isn't the right word
but it's it's a comical organic like
complex system yes okay and then it's a
true though that in a complex system
like that then is every element of it is
it kind of a fractal system where then
each act or each atom has to exactly
it's exactly fractal and says that you
have layers like just like the
restaurant business okay it's composed
of restaurants you see and and for the
restaurant business to be robust at
least robust or perhaps anti fragile you
need every single restaurant to be
fragile well you see so it's the
opposite of Nietzsche what doesn't kill
me makes me stronger I make claims what
kills me makes other stronger that's
right because they learn they learn from
your mistakes and you have evolutionary
forces where the individual sacrifice
for the collective and works within your
biological system even a little cell
level cellular level you have your your
composed of cells if you harm some cells
you see your overall health will improve
now this talk a little bit of a bit more
about that because most people would say
okay when you have a system and if
there's a contagion in it if there's a
cancer in it if there's some kind of
stressor that starts taking over you you
know it's going to spread to the whole
system is what we hear in the banking
you know in the financial crisis that
others a contagion and it spreads out
you're arguing that actually a robust or
an anti fragile system is capable of
seeing this part of the system being
cancered examining from it exactly it to
a you know site the great Yogi Berra
sure a good anti fragile system is a
system in which all mistakes are good
mistakes right you see and a bad system
is one
as again to prefer as yoga Vera you tend
to make the wrong mistakes right so let
me just compare the banking system to
say transportation all right the every
plane crash makes the next plane crash
less likely and and and our
transportation safer now with the
banking system it's because of you may
blame it on government I do blame it on
government but could be some something
else like the way you do blame it I do
sort of blame it on large government use
large banks too big I mean so the the
failure of a bank leads to an increased
probability of failure of the entire
system
and that's a bad system how just with
the banking system what's the best way
to stop that so that you're not you're
not allowing the the problem to
replicate okay I have well the way I
present things is overall I say what the
what federalizes overall system what did
that fragile eyes or a system the three
things number one centralization
decentralization spreads mistakes makes
smaller mistakes like Switzerland
perfectly centralized smack in the
middle of Europe so decentralization
which is where we converge with
libertarians a second one is a low debt
because we've discovered since the
Babylonians that bet that debt has
systemic consequences
whereas equity you know doesn't have
what we now talk about this because I
happen to agree with you that large debt
and you know we're at what 100 percent
of they don't even yeah but I'm just
saying but just today or yesterday Paul
Krugman one of your great friends and
nemec's right yeah but you know he was
ready wait you know these trillion
dollar deficits they don't matter
you know debt large amounts of debt so
why why does debt make things more
fragile let me talk from risk based on
all these economists they do not say
let's put it this way the risk is not
their thing all right so and then so the
second so idea is debt and the third one
I will say skin in the game so let's
talk about that debt leads when you wait
to fragility because let's say that you
have two brothers one of them borrowed
you know they both have provisions about
the future of forecasts predictions
about the future is one brother borrows
the other issues equity the one who
borrows will go bust if he makes a
mistake the one who has actual equity
will fluctuate but will be able to you
know survive a forecast error but is it
also true that the brother with equity
can never really have that big payday
for him but overall for the system you
see the thing is well distributed per se
you know there's an accounting quality
so what you have is that traditionally
that has blown up systems and has been
very good for governments to wage war
you know that's typically but and I'm
not against credit I'm against leveraged
credit you know let it credit is what
made commerce possible so what we have
is talk a little bit about that so then
what what's the difference between
credit where you know I you you give me
a loan and I allowed you know and I say
I'm going to pay you back and that gives
me the ability to get something in the
short run that will help me produce more
in the long run that's a that is a
credit rightly I mean most of banking
started mostly I trust you you're gonna
go to Aleppo Syria and I'm in Florence
and you're going to send me some silk
and you trust me and and then I give you
some money when it's silk
and then my correspondent in Aleppo
would pay you the minute I get myself
that kind of transaction so let's call
leather credit you see where you have
like that conditional on some commercial
transaction being completed okay and it
allows also allows people to finance
some inventory provided the buyers are
so committed buyer that kind of
facilitation of commerce is how it all
started the leather credit and developed
very well before that we had debt in
society and it led to blow ups in in
Babylon and then they had to have debt
Jubilees and then of course the Hebrews
also had that Jubilees and and of course
say neither borrowers or lender shall be
in the settlement you can see that the
the and then you had the Romans then
like that the Greek sort of didn't like
that except for a few intellectual
intellectuals for some reason like mr.
Krugman like that and by that's you know
that's really diminishing the the
currency of the term intellectual yeah
okay but and and then of course the
later on that came back to Europe with
the Reformation and it was mostly to
find us Wars the that revolution is not
financed by that California you told me
that you've read my book on a Kindle or
something that was not financed by that
right financed by equity right so so so
that is not necessary
I mean it's you can use it for
emergencies and and of course we have
you know a lot of societies Catholic
societies
you know akina's was against that and
his statements were stronger than the
Islamic fatwa against them so just to
tell you that we have learned through
history that these things that as
leverage form of theirs can blow things
up so this is where that federalizes now
what we have had of course in this
economy is a growth of that mostly
financed by indirectly by governments
because you blow up you know we're going
to be behind you and and that was you
know that's what we're this is the
problem with too big to fail which went
from being worried to being inscribed in
official policy exactly it became became
sort of like the the mode and then and
but if you cannot separate the three
right large government cannot separate
this inseparable the third point is skin
in the game right when you're a banker
right and you have the upside no doubt
side what are you gonna do create
maximum number of loans that don't blow
up often and collect your bonuses it's
like selling out as money option and
then of course you blow up now how do I
link this to fragility it's very simple
fragility a short volatility you see and
selling loud money option to short a
certain class of volatile and what you
have is a banker has the option he has
the upside and you have a you pay taxes
every April 15 you're paying goes down
side okay that's it all right they may
make money or still cover this downside
so this is this to me is not capitalism
it's misunderstanding of basic rule
and skin in the game you know start with
Hammurabi and it led later on to eye for
eye and let the golden rules right well
I'll talk about how skin in the game
plays out then in the current financial
crisis the what you know we know I mean
I worked on Wall Street I look at you
have a lot of forms of symmetries that
are not visible to the public
corporation right you start your own the
corporation and then you know you go
public now and then you sell it to some
manager not a professional manager is
aim is to look good so you can collect
the bonus he doesn't really care about
the intrinsic health of the corporation
in banking of course you know bankers we
bailed them out the banking I wrote on
the Black Swan I got so many letters the
batterer asked me to prove it because
people didn't believe it and also
bankers of course then like my book in
1983 by 1983 for the last quarter of
1982 banks lost more money in you know
money center banks that quarter then
they made the necessary banking money
central banking and of course we bailed
them out so we start the mode on the
Reagan right and and of course later on
Greenspan made economic I refer to
Greenspan as the fragile ista dodgy
lista exactly okay but it's not just
Greenspan though the fragile isto who's
a system that bailed out by nationalized
continental Illinois and then suddenly
you know allows this and the symmetries
to prevail where is that coming from
though is that I mean this is where you
talk about it's it's I mean big
government is necessary for that but
then the pressure is coming from the
banking industry well the whole
combination big government big central
government was a big you know
uh bailing out authority coupled with a
huge number of regulators who don't have
a clue and who eventually are it
directly on a stake you know because you
know in Africa you see people have
outright corruption where I you know
give you diamonds or something
whereas in Washington you have this
implicit you know corruption I call it
Tony Blair problem the Tony Blair
problem is do a good job and then you go
and go be able to work for five million
dollars er Goma Sachs so whatever you're
going to do as regulator is going to be
there to either facilitate your job at
Goldman Sachs or make regulations
complex enough to make yourself
necessary later on and we have evidence
of that you know going back to that idea
of a kind of fractal system you know
Adam Smith said that you know while each
person is pursuing their own you know
personal desires or their personal
benefits the whole system gets more
robust but you're saying actually that
there are these actors in our system
that are not the the manager of the tank
what makes a did that happen is that it
necessary or is it an inevitable
outgrowth of larger and larger economic
system it's a it's exactly a no it's not
necessary for economic system if you let
things fail if it's not that thing fails
you're going to have concentration of
mistakes you see that plus asymmetry
doesn't work very well plus risk hiding
where you have irregular I mean I was
spent 20 years fighting something called
value at risk that is it was mandated by
regulators and allows people to hide
risk in the tail it's not it's not so to
meet when you have skin in the game it
solves so many problems people are
harmed first by the you know by their
own mistakes so with the banking system
how do we make sure that the banks I
mean this is a common thing that either
banks or mortgage underwriters were able
to sell off whatever you know there is a
there nothing nothing to lose by making
bad deals so that how do you how do you
keep their skin in the game
partially when things are going to be
traded on secondary interest yeah I mean
use these on you actually don't have to
go as far as that and just have at the
level of a bank itself all right so we
don't bail out banks here or bailing out
individuals was true
is a securitized mortgages but we'll
just take a level of the bank Bob Rubin
made hundred twenty million dollars and
stuffing helping to stuff Citibank was
risks and his boss made even more and
then they blew up we're paying for it
and bankers even spit in our face by
paying himself 2010 high level of
bonuses than ever in history all right
okay so how do we solve it very simple I
have rules either I mean I don't believe
in nationalization but I believe as a
taxpayer I would like if a I would have
a list of banks all right what I mean
decentralization solve the problem but
if you don't have the centralization
have a list of institution in this
country all right
if they fail would it be a national
emergency to save them
yes no if the answer is yes you call
them up you tell effectively as of
tomorrow morning 9:00 a.m. you are you
belong to the taxpayer
right the taxpayers should be able to
set your bonuses okay you see that we
don't have a this you know warp
incentive who is who is making that list
I mean it would be whatever I mean it
would be the taxpayer whoever preferred
government yeah government and whatever
however you want to do you want to call
it you know maybe I'm government for
that but saying we cannot build out a
company mm-hmm all right the fact other
civil servants you can see so we have to
decide on their bonuses so what would it
do enforce corporation to be small
enough that they wouldn't be on that
list
run that's one form right another one to
solve associated problems would be what
I call a Tony Blair rule the Tony Blair
rule you cannot go work for the
government and ever later on right have
an income higher income that when you
earn in that correlation I had it and
without paying it to the taxpayer why
because I don't want the regulator to go
make to make something right to
complexify his his stuff to go make five
money for myself go work for Goldman
Sachs now are they are these kind of
thought experiments or do you actually
think that these are rules that could be
implemented in it these are heuristics
I've come up with simple heuristics and
you want to come up with heuristics that
you know are not perfect
but very applicable and solve complex
problems without having side effects
room okay and to me that it's very
important and to have these heuristics
and they would that would clean up
Washington if you have such a changing
room right so you want to work for
Goldman Sachs go work tomorrow on the
sides don't go work you know after a
career and so it should be that working
for Washington should not be investment
strategy right so that would
automatically you control the government
you know I mean on our know you you talk
about decentralization and one of one of
the things that is kind of fascinating
about the global economy over let's say
over the past 50 years I mean you could
argue over the past thousand years is
that in many ways that's becoming more
and more decentralized so certain
certain types of knowledge are more
decentralized than ever before economies
in many ways compete in a way that they
didn't before because investment
you know countries can no longer force
investors to keep their money in a
particular currency in a particular
geographic location so are we
you know even as we're facing a global
crisis are we in fact seeing is this is
this any we have access needing some
ourselves ok talk a little bit about
that and we used to have there's
something in the globalization is
generally a good thing it is yet if you
know how to handle it right if you know
how to handle if you let firms fail ok
the there's something called the element
effect and the island effect in nature
is as follows an island will have much
higher number of species per square
meter than incontinent and actually it's
proportional to the square of the area
yeah so it is a shockingly robust you
know across them so we've lost the
island effect now you have Google
dominant all planets don't like that's
not a problem
the thing is if we stop letting these
firms fail when they become ill right
and they can get large enough to to
dominate government so the problem is if
you let them fail now computer firms I'm
not worried about why what about why
aren't you worried about computer
because you know they're it's a
competitive I'm right Google is a so
it's yeah I mean we can see the end of
Google we can see the end will be no
Microsoft no difference you know the
views no defense for you and at Google
fails tomorrow
or there'll be something else don't
worry it's not like it'll be dramatic
and the government won't save up right
okay so and I don't think they've failed
because for that reason given that they
know the government won't sail but if
you have so you can have some center of
the same concentration that's not a
problem
the problem is we have had in almost all
Western countries nominally they say
well decentralization just
decentralizing but but but effectively
they've had more and more power to the
government central government like the
United States okay so you want decisions
to be spread out now
government debt as a result of
centralization and typically the cause
of more centralization it's a very bad
circle right you see government debt now
it was a debt now transferred to the
government it was a small number of
people calling the shots and some fellow
you know with a beard who sort of looks
like me but I hope not too much it's
printing like there's no tomorrow
right no clue all right why is that and
yeah why why is that not is not exactly
what we need that we need a monetary
stimulus we did I don't know and this
know-it-all understand is that the
mistakes coming from that right can be
monstrous but the point is is that you
need to look at risks of things some
planes may go faster right but that you
wouldn't you know want to be on them
because it got a crash right see we look
at things was a risk adjustment the
standpoint was a risk vision there is
another thing about scaling the game
bureaucrats don't have skin again
especially looking at a local government
people are much more responsible for
deficits but the real cause isn't the
smallest beautiful argue the real cause
is what I explained here everything
comes back to volatility when you are
large you get to be short volatile why a
hundred million pound project in the UK
then to cost 30 percent more in overruns
and problems then a five million pound
project so you have a you know these
errors scale faster and faster and that
is bad for how do we get to a point
because clearly at least in terms of
political economy and the intersection
of big
government and big business there's no
way in hell we're going to let companies
fail anymore it seems I mean and so that
what are the steps that can be taken to
not necessarily scale things back but
just to finally say okay you know what
yet we're letting you go because during
the banking crisis here people are like
look if you let these if you let these I
mean I had Hank Paulson it was certainly
one of your bed Nevarez you know he said
look it's Friday afternoon if we don't
do something this weekend on Monday
money won't come out of the ATM machines
you know they said how do you want a
white act okay you're libertarian are
you yes I see are the vitally well your
other have nationalization of the banks
or moral hazard an assistant I would
rather have moral hazard
well I'm sorry minimize moral ask oh
yeah the way to minimize moral hazard
you'd nationalize immediately and then
and then work with it okay so what we've
done is which is something Sweden did
Hank Paulson okay
the one thing people don't know we're
talk about deficits all yeah all right
right half a trillion dollars every year
we looked at the firm's
foreign and the US that were helped by
the by the Fed during the crisis of 2008
right we looked at the compensation to
their employees half a trillion dollars
now that's not government money right is
government money and that's part of our
deficit Russy that potentially we're
going to have to pay back you know
banking is a very inefficient business
right so I think that we should have
nationalized we wouldn't have had the
problems we've had later and then you'd
be forced to reorganize does do you
think it works in in the in the context
of GM we're not really active we don't
analyze not president was the president
was dictating personnel decision yeah
nationalization is not something to save
the company and bring it back to health
that's like Jason because the system
doesn't work run okay you nationalize
and then you start from you know you
have the government has control and we
no longer hijacked by the bankers what
has happened is the bankers took over
the government and with the Geithner and
servicers Geithner Paulson ever been I
don't know
you know if it's definitely Rubin and
Paulson you know you need a microscope
alright so so you have so it said mafia
of Wall Streeters who took over the
government I mean look at what happened
2010 how can we as taxpayers tolerate
their pain themselves the largest bonus
pool ever in 2010 well it looked to talk
a little bit more about the fragility
and anti fragility argument in in a
excerpt from anti fragility or a part of
it you talked about how you used to go
to after you realize you didn't have to
wear a jacket and tie everywhere you
went to conferences of kind of futurists
and people in the high-tech industry as
well as kind of hip investment bankers
and at first you thought these people
were liberated but then you said that
there was a problem with them that they
were kind of autistic and that they had
an engineering mind well there's
something I mean I'm effectively at
those things energy which is something
called neo mania neo mania is when you
want to change things when you think the
future is in more technological items
and if you look at evidence exact
opposite I mean when a room here or
sitting on chairs Egyptian but mostly
reserved and these cameras go back to
the ancient Babylonians but not what my
point is that when you forecast the
future you tend to add complex items
right with and effectively is what you
could do is remove the complex items
that we are in a modern today that the
cameras are removed but the chair out
keep that's right that's something and
the samurais are models of something
that started a hundred years ago exactly
they would be replaced by something else
so there's something I'll call in the
law and maps the fragility the longer
something has been in print the more
longer it will be a breath right the
longer had technologies anything
non-perishable so things are
supplemental rather than kind of
revolutionary I mean we're not content
no I please even even beyond that it's
like we're more into improvement the
things that exist already then than
anything else well this leads to one of
the things that I thought was most
interesting about antifragility was your
emphasis I mean you're teaching at a you
know you teach risk management you're
good at math or let me but it does what
you get into a lot of arguments about
math
yet your writing style and your your
field of reference is very literary is
very home Oracle okay and and at one
point you wrote that you know the one of
the things that bothers you about
economics and about a lot of social
sciences is there's an absence of
literary culture and that that leads to
a future blindness talked a little bit
about that because the way we're taught
in the u.s. is you know you know kind of
literature the humanities are kind of
[ __ ] or it's like frosting you but I
know III okay I have a my feels a little
different is I like to teach the
classics
not to teach what scott Fitzgerald ate
for breakfast at given day is that to me
is not literature that one right this is
why I don't hang around the three circle
right you are famously anti our chief
arts exactly so you're right about this
is I like the the the distilled wisdom
of the Ancients
it's a remarkable amount of wisdom that
in fact is something anti fragile twit
or at least robust if you map fragility
into has more downside than upside from
random events which is exactly what is
concave in mathematical form of shade is
hates volatility once you buy fragility
that way an existing item anti fragile
means has more upside than the outside
and the first person to really
understand the point in history was
Seneca Seneca was in Greek so he's
probably another great the greatest
master story ossifer healer to Nero to
Tortoni row but he was he was the
wealthiest man in North in his day
supposedly or has or what our or
happened to me for a while you know it
was random and time but he was his idea
was how to get more upside than the
outside in life and and he realized when
you have wealth that you have more
downside than upside from it you get
used to it you have it created and then
he was one of the reasons why I stay
poor because the way I'm always on the
upside well that's what is his idea he
forced himself to become poor we had 500
desks to write on but he faked like he
was a shipwreck once a week something
like that so he understood that notion
of antifragility and and and it's very
strange Scott
other than for Sonico what he committed
suicide it was dignity the whole idea is
the idea for a stoic Azalea is that you
can't control randomness you can control
how you behave right and he behaves the
way he died the way he wanted to die
Welch's was honor talk about I mean
because one of the things that is I I
suspect is one of the reasons why you
are as kind of popular and as which
isn't quite the right word but as
dashing a figure as you are is that in
the United States certainly it's rare
for an intellectual particularly one
who's good at math to also have any
sense of you know that the Romans
existed as something you know something
we could still learn from you decided at
an early age you were interested in
becoming a philosopher talk about that
and then how that linked into the work
that you're doing okay well I mean I
wanted to be philosopher from the
beginning but then I decided then there
was civil war and Lebanon I left came
back from France and I went back and I
realized I had too many books to read
and and and I loved reading but I hated
to be given books to read because if
you're bored with it you have you like
you lose the option I like option L well
and you're you you think the autodidact
to use the optionality of switching to
finding your own path rather than being
in a straitjacket alright of university
stuff like that so then I realized that
I had better study something more
technical alright and and then of course
I continued to lives one technical right
and one non-technical and the technical
led to option trading alright and the
option trading led to more doctorate
really related to probability theory
applied to options and and some problems
you know in off model you know some
obscure stuff so so this is sort of so
my background was technical by day
literally at night you see with a class
the classics aren't really Roman but I
think like a Roman the Arabs and the
Greeks think in the same way they love
theory the respect theory the respect
ideas the respect
so the same things top-down right
whereas although the Arabs were you know
into systems that were bottom-up but
they thought wise they respect top-down
and the Romans were were immensely
heuristic right and I mean it's
experience versus exactly racism versus
abstract it is it is a form of tinkering
and trial and error and then there are
Romans understood optionality they
understood that their constitution the
Republic was made through adversity see
bouncing back every time getting better
and and and rather liquor goes from top
down thinking of how things should be
and in a way they they figured out what
what what took me a long time you know
to be able to put down on paper
optionality the option of changing not
being locked into a plan they understood
it but at the same time also using the
past as a guide or as as a framework
exactly the same as talking Lindy
effectors as technologies what has
survived what has survived has to
survive for a reason right so it could
be hidden reason they don't understand
you don't try to rationalize right so
you're also I mean but you're not you're
not slavishly devoted to replicating the
past or preserving them that's the idea
the idea is as follows whatever change
are going to do needs to be incremental
and you know minimize adverse
consequences of it and and and you you
don't believe your ideas you only
believe what you see this so this is
really I mean you're you're very
interested in the limits of knowledge
rather than the perceived power of an
all-encompassing universe exactly it's
exactly the opposite of someone said you
know what are you doing I said take the
theory of everything I'm doing the exact
opposite how to make decision if you
don't understand everything right so the
idea is you do have a single kind of
line of thought that runs through
everything no I mean well okay my line
thread is probability
probabilities have a superb thing going
for them they add up to want right so
and and so there are mathematical things
that that come from that the fact that
probably add up to one is that you never
have the whole story you see so and you
never see a hundred percent of things
and stuff like that there is a thread
but the way I framed it here
is again it's a probabilistic thing this
is hard to explain you know without
graphs is that whatever has more
downside than upside from random events
has some attributes and these attributes
are shared by everything that has these
attributes for example if I take a
medicine and I don't understand how it
works we don't have a lot of history I
face more downside than upside you see
or I should act as if I face more
outside than upside because benefits are
seen and small and when you go against
mother nature
benefits can only be small right you see
against the history of nature if you're
not very ill so so all these
considerations come from the same things
are you long and often or short an
option and in life you make decisions
where we have maximum option right so
it's not like a theory of everything is
a decision-making rules that are
distilled that are to me not as original
as as they appear they're not
particularly original if we are selling
now 2000 years ago at Seneca stable and
he had the table right he had the table
and the next day would force you to
become poor again right but you can
enjoy dinner and who were talking nobody
you know these people say what these
guys talking about right alright this so
unoriginal don't tell us something we
don't know alright so that was that
would have been you know so that's sort
of like my yeah how does that fit in
with I mean you you have shown another
reason why I think you have you know
really capture the public imagination is
because you speak freely and openly and
hostile e towards your intellectual
adversaries and you've I say no I have a
commitment if I saw fraud don't shop
fraud I am the fraud okay
so like for everyone well let me run
through a couple of your greatest hits
cuz they're really good at New York
Times columnist Thomas Friedman you
called so vile and harmful that when you
accidentally make eye contact with them
you became nauseated Joseph Stiglitz the
Nobel Prize winning economist you talk
about Stiglitz a syndrome which is what
happens when public intellectuals have
absolutely no responsibility for stupid
and bad predictions Paul a Nobel
laureate Paul Samuelson is an
intellectual fraud
Paul Krugman you I don't think you in
your entire corpus have anything good to
say no I mean Samuelson equivalence is a
different
I didn't say a poor probably and then I
don't remember and there but I say that
they have no consciousness of risk so
they proposed a model we should follow
it they don't have no no idea of risk
and I think risk would come first
because you're endangering the public by
getting reduced models and but the idea
that runs the whole thing is let me be
technical for two minutes so I can relax
sure something called Jensen's
inequality which is like when you have a
convex payoff mm-hmm
your benefit from randomness and when
you have concave payoff any error of
your model is likely to hurt you right
okay and and typically they have concave
payoffs like the policies by Krugman all
these can be voiced as concave payoffs
right nothing wrong except they don't
know it right you see this is what I
mean is missing non-linearity of ideas
it's a little technical so in the end I
have a section showing you know how you
know we can talk about mistakes made in
economics by having concave bails what
is your goal as I as a public figure I
mean you know I don't want to be a
public figure I spent five years with
the Black Swan but the first six months
nine months one year I you know walked
around thinking it was nice to go to
Davos and then I didn't like it
came back home what I'm attracted to
many empty suits and also what's my
profession is to write books okay I only
write articles let me tell you I only
write articles because to explain some
of the idea of the books and I do
technical papers and books and
everything else I do is because a
publisher wants me to write the op-eds
the rest I don't so well then let me put
it a little bit differently what are you
hoping that your ideas how do they add
to the public understanding of you know
of how a good society would work better
and what kinds of mistakes what it has
already led to two beautiful results I'm
it was David Cameron when I was
contacted by him and his administration
took us before to help you know I told
on us and I'm not public intellectual
but I can we can talk about my ideas
through my books I'm not going to write
articles and we can have conversation
right it led to being demonized by
sections of the British public who cares
and and as well as here but it had an
effect but I say I'm a lot it's not bad
people can pick up these ideas very
quickly my point is to have a systematic
approach to making decisions under
incomplete information and under
complete understanding of thing and
build a society that doesn't blow up if
someone makes a mistake which is the
same thing now
the society has seems to have unique
attributes and I'm not the first person
to think of these matters
it's just I've devoted my life to the
furthering of them talking actually
about that in terms of you know mistakes
that then you don't blow up and you talk
about iatrogenic effects okay of
interventions into the economy or into
the social system because we've had this
we've had a bunch of blow ups and then
typically what happens is that we need a
bigger government you know if government
is partly to blame or partly responsible
for something then we need a bigger
government response in order to fix it
and you talk about that how do we break
that so if you a negativo via negativa
is if if I want to cure diabetes and I
give you any drug alright and people
typically take drugs then they have to
take more drugs of side effects
multiplied and they spend their lives
making Pharma richer so you have
unintended multiple you know chains
unattended consequences branching out
alright if you remove say sugar from the
person or food and make someone starve
for 600 calories a day for six weeks no
you can gain your weight back and you
remove diabetes with the same
probability as having good drugs right
all right but there's no side effects
it's called via negativa from Orthodox
theology via negativa is you can't you
can't figure out what God is but I can
safely say what he's not all right
so the via negativa
permeates this book is a robust decision
making stuff like that so what we should
remove so removing is to me is like
removing some sections of government
it's probably the best thing we could
achieve but
since Reagan you know I seen it done but
he's a problem right because you were
just saying I mean he his rhetoric was
I'm getting rid of government but in
fact he wasn't he's nailed up he bailed
out cotton well nationalize the bank
yeah nationalize the bank continental
Illinois and then later on these people
blew up in the crash of 87 right from
bad risk management just to tell you I
mean it was not a it was but he bit
Thatcher came removal all right removal
is removal something harmful doesn't
have long-term side effects right
okay as a first step by then you can see
what what what we became addicted to
addition and academics like to add and I
like to complexify and practitioners we
like simple and relaxed attractive
things who were your intellectual heroes
I mean when I when I read your work and
I looked at the you know at the index of
various books and I mean I'll see a
couple of references to Hayek or Karl
Popper Joseph Schumpeter is in the in
the index for anti fragility but you say
these are not I mean economists are not
the people who have who have generated
your ideas you know where did they come
from and how much of it is personal I
mean you grow a lot of it's personal a
lot of interest yes none of it is
personal but I would say I two things
the first one that
Schumpeter is a creative destruction you
connect any columns cannot come up with
an idea as brilliant to that so had to
be someone before him and turned out to
be called Marx right well I get resulted
about yeah recycling recycling me tree
and each she understands the John is
young and Apollonian that you have the
reason you an easy and I have those dark
forces and in here fat Tony my principal
character from New Jersey whose
anti-intellectual Fat Tony takes
Socrates to the cleaner by reusing
vindicating Nietzsche is what you don't
understand isn't necessarily stupid
right did what you don't see it doesn't
it's not not there what is not
intelligible nature said is not
necessarily unintelligent right which is
the government they do intelligent
things and they can't abide by these
forces so that was that was neatly I
would say is more than anything
it Karl Popper note because Karl Popper
isn't called popper I mean the idea of
Black Swan dates from Romans and it was
elaborated of course by someone called
Victor Borgia a lot of people who wrote
on absence of not a you know evidence
versus evidence of absence in the French
literature before him and actually
Nietzsche picked it up from brochures
book on Greek skeptics and of course you
go Sixtus empirica so their lineage and
of course al-ghazali the Arab
philosopher the Arabic language
philosopher al-ghazali the the all these
people have developed this notion of a
negative information is more important
than positive information so I would say
popper is just said that people
assimilated was popper I access that so
he thought of that but then when I went
to do history I realize that there were
vastly more intelligent deeper thinkers
about the problem the only thing popper
did that nobody else did is this
argument about the future being
unpredictable because you have to
forecast if technologies that are up for
castable that is a popper not the popper
of you know that people talk about now
when you think about the future or you
or you optimistic or pessimistic is that
the wrong way well I mean it's the wrong
way to view it we I'm you know it's the
wrong way to view it I my view of the
future is not you know they don't have
to be right so you have to have a
dominant strategy to act as a few
pessimistic like when I say that I don't
want the pilot of the plane to be
optimistic you see but I want the flight
attendants to be extremely after this
right you see so it's functional like I
don't believe in yeah well then you talk
about how pilots who are too comfortable
with their knowledge and everything
they're bad pilots they're the ones who
have the errors exactly yeah you have to
have paranoid pilots and stressed all
the time by so technology is weakens
makes actually FDA order of the FFA
figured out that makes the flights less
safe but the again I take a stance again
against knowledge knowledge isn't what
run society its knowledge is a lot
larger narrative that comes after we do
facts there so so much we narrate you
know so and so much we do that without
the complete theory of things you see
this is my central idea well to talk a
bit more about cap
ilysm in that or and of system where
it's not
it isn't knowledge per se but you've
talked about that it you know a lot of
people talk about it as you know what's
great about capitalism it creates
incentives that lead to success when
actually capitalism in your view is
about decentralization about creating
disincentives and failing early it's
exact opposite of incentive is
disincentives right is have people have
a since mohammed rafi we've had
civilized society people living together
get only able to do that when when
people are accountable for the mistakes
where where are the kind of signal
incidents of decentralization that's
leading to better outcomes but you know
broadly speaking where do you see that
in either in the united states or in the
West or in particular pockets in
subculture I mean you have a take
Switzerland as a culture where nobody
can name the president easily the Canaan
president of France this is a good
society because you have a lot of
volatility but you know at the local low
level right micro level translating to
novo the other macro level stability so
this is Switzerland this is a world with
centralized system now what you know
have you seen the third man the Carol
yeah of course you know Everson Wells
cares Harry Lime says look the Swiss
have been around for hundreds of years
and they produced the cuckoo clock is
that what does that uh is that a cheap
shot I think is very cheap yacht flood
but the other thing I discovered myself
through time by looking for the surface
we typically attributed over satellites
country actually to the the second the
reverse of nation-state
you know nation-state were born in Egypt
and failed born in China and failed and
then born and get France okay because
the Roman Romans were too smart to have
nation-states or Roman hands with
city-states mm-hmm okay and then system
city-states were although within a
larger context of an empire it was a Pax
Romana what I call the barbell you'll
see no more than Commerce and then go
live and that was how you know my SS
really grew up city-states so the French
effectively what they did is they had
probably the weakest
monarchy as you can see from
multiplication of languages in a country
not integrated area where the central
government had no access and you had
more people speaking French and st.
Petersburg than you did in the province
or France except along the tax lines so
so France it was only integrated after
Napoleon and it took a while to national
education system stuff like that - and a
train system to integrate France so
France and look we have 400 pieces you
know so so France was in effect a
diverse country till I would say well
into the 20th century when after the
first war and now you know and it's you
know it's common in the u.s. to just
mock France or France's everything that
were not but France is also an economic
powerhouse that has what 70 million
people but as you know one of the
richest countries on the planet so but I
mean they're doing okay fifty-five
million level even zero so then there is
power from that kind of century okay I
think you don't with I don't quite
believe I mean if you look at the
strengths of France the centralization
came to France mostly after the goes
policies mm-hmm that later after the war
as you know of course it has not been
you cannot have to give the success of
France to centralization okay you see
the French were already powerful in a
rich country without too much
centralization that's a translation but
without being hang up on France the idea
of deriving the rule from saturation the
problem is sighs you know visibly you
can have centralized government in a
small village problem is sighs the
problem is a size gets larger okay you
have some gains of becomes the scale
what it is but you have some losses in
governance and a lot of other things and
this is you because the more homogenous
you become the easier it is to to be
wiped out to be wiped out to make many
mistakes and be wiped out this is the
island effect at work you see so and you
don't want and what we have had in this
country is a
rise of the central government
progressive rise of central government
and you know particularly other deficits
are the words of central government and
as a human figure it out
he said small states and steady states
the law of Commerce and a lot of
governance love war okay and that's what
justifies a large government whether
they fill a war so they immediately look
like Germany after they got together at
war and and you can see it and and and
there's no justification for logical
other than war and they're not good at
now you say that you're not a
libertarian but a lot of this overlaps
with yes considered so why aren't you a
liberal well I mean I whatever I don't
know what a libertarian is live at 10 I
mean I like like I'm risk based person
and I want what my libertarianism would
be not the optic libertarianism like you
know there's a philosophical liberalism
that you know freedom comes first good
right and so much as I want errors to be
multiplied that's it right you know I
want as we multiplied and also it's a
kind of John Stuart Mill you you like
the idea of experiments and living
exactly it errors need to be multiplied
this is is that so I'm more of a in that
sense I'm not conservative hundred
percent but more of a left-wing
conservative if you want you see the
left Iran called libertarians you know
right-wing hippies that was there they
go so left wing conservatives that would
plan exactly
so it would be a I'm in a way you know
I'm conservative conservationist you
know I want to not break things that
have been around for a long time there's
own laws ik and but I'm not against you
know things provided come from tinkering
not from some radical transformation of
things and the most successful states
and history have been
city-states okay or small and even if we
had a lot of small wars they produced
great things and of course you know
sometimes you have an empire that
prevents them all cost from waging Wars
so even better you say like Pax Romana
or Pax Romana
let's you know we'll close out here
right you you've mentioned the barbed
effect or you know kind of bar
bell-shaped distribution several times
where you you know you have certain
things at the end but not so much in the
middle yes you also write a lot in
antifragility about barbells in terms of
lifting you at one point so that you
could deadlift 330 pounds that I didn't
say I could deadlift let's say if I did
let you know there's better this more
because we haven't have a stack of
weights out here at the wheel I don't
know confined talk it talked a little
bit about because I mean this is one of
the things that I find both I didn't say
I was okay I was a know what happened
that the beauty of this book the critics
could incapable of addressing a central
point
so they nitpick and and and anything on
wrong things like this more than 30
times another interesting thing about
this book even tell one thing before we
get there it's written in a way to be
loved by the reader and hated by the
journalist why because you can't get
into it you can't figure out
you can't skim it if it if it means
anything one of the things that I am an
admirer of your work in the book that I
was like I get the pose and I want to
get to the information which is another
way of saying what you said that it is
it's true it's it's an experience it's
not it isn't something that you can kind
of a strip mine exactly the meaning it's
it's very discursive it's and you go
deep deeper different topics don't live
it I think so someone who wants spread
their ideas every page you don't live in
some way it's kind of curious that you
are so popular in the business market
because most business books will end
with like bullet points at the end of
what this chapter was about I saw them
have that I sort of have that but was
good let me tell you what this book is I
have learned from experience I don't
really okay so I enjoy writing all right
what the minute I'm bored writing I get
a stop all right so and I've developed
some experience with it with a little
quickly with the Black Swan that to make
sure that no content of any section can
be discovered without surprising czar
either somewhere okay so you have titles
and subtitles that don't really match so
they're not bored text books bore you
right so I'm I realized okay that
critics would hate it because I want
skin books but people who read will not
hate it that critic needs to get to the
whole idea
to me of the Black Swan the people were
frustrated and an empiricist if you sell
3 million copies of a book writing in
some way I expect that that the style
isn't I'm not going to be lectured about
style so and then of course you know for
the critics come in and they tell you
it's a mess no you didn't see the order
from the table of content or name
voluntarily so you realize you're
playing games with them probably their
lecture you have to write when they've
sold you know this you know the you know
the Black Swan sold more probably in a
day than they saw in a lifetime so you
get the idea
make sure you're not going to say that
the market is always right and that you
know billion Elvis fans can't be wrong
no my point is that you don't someone
who is onyx is yacht the limo doesn't
take lectures on finance from someone
who just wrote a subway right all right
that's the idea that you can take ideas
maybe if you want but you don't you know
take instructions on how to write a book
so if you want to write a book it take
either instructions from the harry
potter lady right that's it all right so
or you can take instructions from from
Seneca we survived two thousand years
but definitely not from some academic at
Cambridge who sold twenty two hundred
copies you get the idea so this is this
is what I have to say about lecture
being lecture but yet these are the ones
we're at book review so you have to
bypass the saying and it's only a
difficult phase in the beginning well
you get out of the way and then as with
a Black Swan then you have an open five
years for people to discover your book
without them right and that's what
happened so to just end with barbells
your preferred workout plan then is talk
about your you know the Nasim Tuck tala
okay then I apply it first why do I talk
about myself but because as I say here
scanning again I'm not allowed to give
you advice I don't tell you what you
should buy I tell you what's in my
portfolio people are shocked I'll talk
about my portfolio yeah because it's
unfair I'd be a Stiglitz telling you
what you should be doing with that being
horn if I'm wrong it's unethical for me
for my own system of ethics okay so
therefore I can't tell you I can tell
you what I do so what I do now I came up
21 days of eating without exercise but
what I do is I try to lift weight
and imitating you know and then I try to
not take you know instructions but try
to find big doorman at the gym who lift
weight and see what the routine is and
imitate it without having a trainer
observe what they do not what they tell
you all right
because if you ask them you know they
give you a different story so that's
sort of like my idea so I take walks
long walks 20 20 30 hours a week of
walking and just one thing that you know
happened later on to discover the
Nietzsche said never trust ideas you
haven't had walking right so I walk a
lot and I lift a very heavy weight and
that's it can I just you know is
Nietzsche of the best life guide
especially he told one story which is
very interesting his if you imitated him
you wouldn't be here right now would you
well a Nietzsche was sickly from the
beginning so you know for for his days
he did very well for a sick leave of the
beginning but me tree was not know his
you know he's one you know do what he
says not what he does no I mean in what
senses and Nietzsche is not the baddest
uber bench is but but he didn't take a
lot of personal risk of his life that's
true I try to take more personal risks I
think my guide is a neat trait so much
as the people I'm covered by Nietzsche
my guides are the classics the respect I
have for the elders is so high compared
to Nietzsche because they've been around
longer and and but if you look at how
the elders words is the only sitting
they respected discouraged and and of
course actions not words and stuff like
that and and also skin in the game as a
you know a rank so and now I'm taking a
risk not with whatever I'm take front
take risk with this I know that I'm
taking I'm going against the
establishment say things the way they
are lawsuits are probably gotta come so
what the more risk I take for my ideas
that better I do that'll you the matter
I do why is if you fail that I you know
I learn from your mistakes that's true
and also in you know you probably if you
have a cause and we have similar cause
for a lot of things it will probably
help but I have absolutely
the only thing that makes me feel that I
am my idea of living is taking risks for
four causes so the more risks I take now
of being attacked by academia by someone
someone putting some note on my dinner
table and a restaurant or the more I do
the more I feel good about you know
myself well hey thank you thank you very
much I want to I think we'll end it
there
nice um Nicholas Taleb author most
recently of antifragility thanks for
talking to us
Thanks